sigue la huelga en este país Aunque
recién una refinería del departamento de
los buses de agon esto es en el sur de
Francia cerca de Marsella ha terminado
con la huelga es una refinería de la
estadounidense eso Epson móvil y además
el gobierno cumplió con la promesa que
había hecho ayer de intervenir un nuevo
depósito de gasolina esto es en el norte
del país el depósito de flandes cerca de
dunkerque y que pertenece a la francesa
total esto obviamente Porque esa es una
de las regiones más afectadas por la
falta de gasolina entonces en total
tenemos cuatro refinerías y ya no
consideramos la que sacaba de bajar de
la huelga y seis depósitos si no
consideramos este depósito que también
acaba de ser intervenido por el gobierno
seis trabajadores requisicionados es
decir obligados a trabajar para poder
distribuir la gasolina entre tanto ayer
total la francesa se reunió finalmente
con el sindicato más radical al cgt les
propuso Un aumento de del 6% más una
prima Todo esto el próximo año de un
sueldo por mes a los trabajadores pero
ellos no están contentos están pidiendo
un 10% de reajustes de sus salarios no
quieren no quieren primas no quieren
premios sino que quieren realmente Un
aumento en sus salarios el presidente
Manuel macrón fue entrevistado en la
televisión pública dijo que el sindicato
cgt no puede seguir paralizando el país
y aseguró que la situación se va a
normalizar la próxima semana Mientras
tanto este sindicato cgt está llamando a
todos los sectores de la energía a los
trabajadores de todos los sindicatos de
la energía de los servicios del comercio
a que se unan hasta huelga y ellos dicen
no es solamente por nosotros sino que
por todas las medidas que toma el
gobierno de Manuel macron a quien acusan
de noticias falsas recordemos que hace
poco circuló una noticia como que los
trabajadores de las petroleras ganaban
5000 euros mensuales los que es bastante
dinero para un sueldo medio francés